[Musique]
c'est bon
oui alors donc bienvenu bienvenue sur
nancy dans si 2010 est super tournoi
r'n'b c'est rapide rapide et blitz donc
[Musique]
voilà on a un super tournoi donc
j'essaie juste de calais un petit peu
pour la diffusion parce qu'il ya pas mal
de trucs se compliquer voilà donc on me
fait signe alors voilà donc on me dit
que le son est bon donc a priori le
volume est bon donc donc super donc vous
m'entendez donc vous pourrez suivre un
petit peu sur le chat qui se passe de
loin parce que je ne peux pas vérifier à
la fois mais alors donc sur ce thomas de
nancy qu'est ce qu'il vous faut dire
alors vous voyez sur l'écran un petit
peu comment ça va se passer pour ce
direct ont ils dès 15h10 bon alors pour
vous il ya toujours un peu de délai
entre la fin des désinscriptions bien
sûr et le début du tournoi
donc on peut espérer que ça va démarrer
vers vers vraiment des partis dits
longtemps dc 10 ème quart d'heure vingt
minutes dont vous voyez qu'il ya une
applet
qui est connecté directement les chèques
électroniques que vous voyez sur l'image
et en même temps donc on pourra à la
fois voir les joueurs et chic et sur
l'image et on pourra aussi le temps en
temps faire d'autres d'autres vues donc
on va se concentrer bien sûr sur la
table numéro 1 du tournoi pour ce
tournoi de blitz et puis éventuellement
plus tôt demain on pourra aussi de temps
en temps les voir ce qui se passe sur la
table numéro 2 on a aussi une vue sur la
table numéro 2 mais pour le blitz
s'avère délicat de gérer deux échiquier
tellement les parties et bien sûr son
sont tendus rapide
donc on va essayer de se concentrer sur
uniquement la table numéro un alors ceci
dit ce qu'on va suivre aussi pendant ce
tournoi qui va être intéressant
c'est bien entendu voilà la liste des
listes des participants
voilà comme vous pouvez voir ici donc là
on l'a quand même de gros joueurs qui
sont là puisque vous le voyez laurent
frayssinet donc vous savez toussaint
c'est un de nos plus grands joueurs
français de tous les temps
numéro 3 français il a été vice champion
du monde chez les jeunes deux fois il a
deux titres de champion de france et son
actif
et donc voilà c'était vraiment un très
très grand joueur qu'on va suivre avec
avec attention donc commis la numéro 1
au classement elo dans ce tournoi de
blitz et bien il va sans doute jouer la
première partie la table e1 et on peut
supposer qu'il va y rester un certain
temps avant que des joueurs de
de grand calibre le rejoignent alors il
y en a derrière il ya du très lourd
puisque on a milk raël gourévitch alors
gourévitch qui est michael gourévitch
c'est bien entendu un super joueur qui
fait partie toujours des meilleurs
joueurs du monde avec un classement ici
en rapide à 2681 c'est tout à fait
exceptionnel c'est très très très très
fort et il a été aussi et bien
entraîneur du très grand garry kasparov
ont là c'est un des joueurs qui a
entraîné kasparov et sur des gones à la
tv on a eu la chance de l'interviewer ça
devait être en 2000 ou 2001 c'était à
bâle en suisse vous pouvez retrouver
cette vidéo dans le catalogue diagonale
tv faites une recherche sur des gones al
tv michael gourévitch ça devait être à
bâle en suisse et vous avez une
interview de may cry gourévitch qui nous
explique quels étaient les points
importants du travail qu'il avait fait
avec kasparov et donc je vous en dis pas
plus je vous invite à aller voir cette
interview de michael gourévitch donc
ex-entraîneur du mythique garry kasparov
alors en trois ans glissants à bilel
belhassen qui est alors maître
international il n'est pas grand maître
il vient se glisser en blitz entre voyez
les grands maîtres
il ya un deux trois quatre cinq grands
maîtres et bilel belhassen se trouve
classée numéro 3 parmi au milieu de ses
cinq grands maîtres donc c'est une c'est
une performance il doit très fort en
blitz on le suivra sans doute on aura
l'occasion de le voir à la table un très
certainement et le troisième très très
fort joueur de ceux de ce blitz qui sera
sans doute là aussi pour de même pour le
rapide
c'est daniel friedman voilà qui est donc
allemand et qui profite la proximité de
nancy bien sûr avec la frontière
allemande pour sans doute venir jouer ce
tournoi et qui donc bien sûr est et là
aussi encore une fois un très grand
joueur qui va nous proposer très
certainement de belles parties et qu'on
devrait voir aussi tableaux peints
ensuite on a un joueur qui est connue
bien connue de tous de tous les français
et des parisiens en particulier en ile
de france puisqu'il fait énormément de
tournois notamment de rap tournant
rapide ces embryons chez katia fera le
grand maître international lui aussi
donc paix avec là aussi un très bon
niveau 1 messieurs en lice 2006 en lots
de nationalité française maintenant même
s'il est d'origine l'anru je crois
qu'ils les russes d'origine
à vérifier et donc il est
c'est un habitué il connaît tous les
trucs idée attention il est redoutable
dans tous ses tournois de bliss de
rapides
il a l'habitude d'en faire beaucoup
ensuite alors que les parties vont
commencer donc il faut absolument que
l'on revienne voilà ça y est à blain
pour voir ce qui se passe voilà avec
voilà on s'y trompe pas la partie entre
eux alors ça va être très intéressant
partie entre laurent frayssinet et est
donc un amateur donc c'est là que ça
c'est ça l'intérêt aussi de ce tournoi
voilà partis entre leur ont fait signer
un amateur
qu'ils s'appellent docteur c'est fabien
cage ganic en 1814 rôles fabien cailler
ganic
alors je sais pas du tout comme il est
classé dans le tournant à 1814 et l'eau
il doit quand même être alors je vais
regarder je vais je lis gérard dans la
liste justement alors qu'hadji ganic
1980 à 1988 quand même un 63e au
classement alors apparemment oui le le
classement là et bizarrement 1814 alors
qu'apparemment il serait plutôt 1988
voilà en tout cas un rapide voilà donc
là il se dira il effaça à laurent
frayssinet notre ami fabien calcagni
qu'il est face à laurent fera signer
avec les noirs
face à laurent frayssinet
avec les noirs fabien 15 ganic donc il
va mission avoir beaucoup beaucoup de
mal on peut s'attendre à une partie à
sens unique mais bon on sait jamais on
sait jamais il ya parfois des surprises
mais bon elles sont assez rares infos
skier
donc là il doit y avoir encore des
doit y avoir
[Musique]
d'avoir des officiels qui
les officiels qui donnent encore des
dernières consignes que ce soit larbitre
l'organisateur sur sur le tourment
alors c'est parti voilà donc alors c'est
parti pour laurent frayssinet avec donc
cette ouverture cavaliers 3 puis
ouverture de pions dame tranquillement
on est alors dans une sorte de je ne
sais pas c'est une variante alors avec
des cinq tôt je sais plus le nom de
cette variante que vous pas souvent
cavalier prendre des 5 de la part de
frayssinet après la prise en dessin
qu'elle va les prendre il a l'air de s'y
connaître fabien cage ganic là dans
cette ouverture pour l'instant cavalli
prend la dame va reprendre pour
fonctionner sans doute assez vite
voyez on remarque que la plaie tu
réponds très rapidement quasiment
instantanément voire même parfois là je
vais devoir le coup se jouer avant avant
que le coup soit vidéo se finit donc on
est vraiment bien en phase là donc frais
s'ils ne viennent jouer le 4
mais ses pions centre avec la dame au
centre la dame est très très bien placé
au centre là pas facile pour les notes
se développer poussé quatre coups normal
attention maintenant aussi voilà petit
rock très bien précis mais voilà aussi
fait le petit rock pour l'instant les
blancs sont bien beau de position pour
les blancs développement simple facile
pièce portant sur la d6 maintenant les
noirs menace peut-être entre guillemets
de jouer faut aussi ce qu'ils attaquent
et la dame et le fou derrière ce qui
aurait été un tout petit peu dangereux
donc voilà freyssinet enlève sa dame
tout de suite pour la mettre en page 5
attention c'est une dame qui de ce côté
là du rock et bien évidemment fait
pression sur les noirs une pression si
un petit peu sur le rock on sait jamais
imaginé que ce fou plus tard à belvianes
en d3 et on pourrait avoir des menaces
de match 7
à noter aussi que le voilà a g6 alors ça
sert à ça affaiblit un peu c'est pas
trés trés bon je pense j'ai si c'est
très très high oui ça me paraît très
très dangereux
adam est très très bien passé en a six
le cavalier peut venir en gestion menacé
un math force et en achète ça obligerait
le flou de prendre reprendre du fou et
on la dame est attaqué et où va la dame
parce qu'on peut pas jouer le 6 pourquoi
parce que justement le fou 6-4 tout
alors de coucy si on fait cavaler prend
fou prend faut prendre la dame est
attaquée van damme 1,8 fou et 6 ensuite
et c'est matt forcé en g7 donc attention
laurent frayssinet menace un match fort
c'est la base de la menace et corrigé 5
attaque pour faire maths fou prend force
est fou prendre où va la dame elle bouge
et ensuite floue et 6 menace maths et
c'est fini et pas de réponses contre
fluxys
voilà donc menace de frayssinet kg c'est
voilà le coup j'ai si c'est vraiment
dernier coup s'il fallait faire ça a
l'air déjà foutu
je pensais que tu en fait peut-être roi
je suis peut-être qu est-ce qui fait
alors il semblerait qu'il ait joué mais
que le problème de rafraîchissement de
venir qu'est-ce qu'il a joué voilà il ya
joué je suis très c'est ça mais il
semblerait que notre échiquier
voilà donc ici sur cette cette vue on
peut aussi voilà il joue permis kg 5
freyssinet prise prise attaque la dame
voilà est-ce que non c'est bloqué sur
l'échiquier blocage pas pourquoi un
problème bon c'est pas grave on va
suivre la partie en vidéo donc attention
développe les pièces et j'ai toujours
l'échiquier bloqués je sais pas pourquoi
peut-être qu'il ya un problème de mise à
jour là et là je peux pas savoir ce qui
se passe il faudrait savoir pourquoi le
les échiquiers n'en voit plus le fichier
tour d2 pour le rang fasciné
c'est dommage qu'on n'ait plus la partie
alors un petit réglage sont toutes à
leur truc qui va pas tourner 8
à 5 pour laurent frayssinet ils bloquent
sur les dames
les noirs font repli
prise en p 6 pour prend
je jette un oeil pour voir si les autres
partis sont bloqué de la même façon
ça a l'air de marcher sur les autres
semblant qui est un problème sur le
premier échiquier ça c'est un peu
dommage on peut changer de parti on peut
aller voir jeter un oeil
puisqu'on a un problème sur cette
première on peut aller voir un oeil sur
on peut jeter un oeil sur la partie
numéro deux avec gourévitch
on va changer de parti voilà on croyait
la partie avec gourévitch est donc là on
est où une troisième coup et la voile à
savoir de marché sur la partie - rich
pas ce qu'il s'est passé
en plus j'ai logiciel qui qui plante
donc vraiment c'est vraiment le c'est le
bonheur il ya vraiment des problèmes
cette partie avec gourévitch on verra ça
après ici il y aurait huit chalets noir
donc face à volkan de creux cher avec
les blancs à 2015 lots dont une partie
où les où les blancs comment une
position intéressante
pas mal pour wolfgang ici dans cette
partie avec les blancs pas de pas de
pions de retard les blancs la colonne
ses voiles noirs aurait pu peut-être la
contester cette colonne vous préférez
c'est de chasser la dame
je pensais
alors donc dans cette partie toujours
entre creux cher et gourévitch pourrait
vite qu'avec les noirs
viens de jouer eux quatre
alors l'intérêt du coup et 4 très
certainement ici c'est que ça bouge un
petit peu ça contrôle c'est surtout le
contrôle case d3 c'est bon pour ce pas
vraiment le foule était déjà bloqué par
son propre opinion mais aux quatre jeux
contre la casse des 3 donc je peux je me
fous des trois avec un fou très bien
placé dans le camp ennemi
mais les blancs pourrait contester avec
fouet fin sans doute beaucoup pour les
blancs ici il faut enfin la solution
alors j'ai tenté de relancer par
notre ami de ses parents quand ils
arrêtent de planter
non
zéro je vais arrêter le flux là pour le
reprendre
je les reprends tout à l'heure parce
qu'il va falloir sans doute que je
redémarre ans est cette machine a tout
de suite donc arrêt du stream et un
redémarrage pour la prochaine ronde